So
let's say,
let's say you go into a,
you can do this in a room,
it's quite fun to do it just when you're
sitting in a room like a room,
maybe your bedroom,
you can sit there and just sort of
meditate on it.
Think,
okay,
if I wanted to spend 10 minutes making
this room better,
what would I have to do?
And you have to ask yourself that,
right?
It's not a command.
It's like our genuine question and
things will pop out in the room that you
know,
you like there's a stack of papers over
there that's kind of bugging you and you
know that maybe little order there would
be a good thing and you know,
you haven't.
There's some rubbish behind your
computer monitor that you haven't
attended to for like six months and the
room would be slightly better if it was
a little less dusty and the cables
weren't all tangled up the same way.
And like if you,
if you allow yourself just to consider
the expanse in which you exist at that
moment,
there'll be all sorts of things that'll
pop out in it that you could just fix.
And you know,
I might say,
well,
if you were coming to see me for
psychotherapy,
this easiest thing for us to do first
would just be to get you to organize
your room.
You think,
well,
is that psychotherapy?
And the answer is,
well,
it depends on how you conceive the
limits of your being.
And I would say start where you can
start,
you know,
if,
if something announces itself to you,
which is a strange way of thinking about
it,
as in need of repair that you could
repair,
then hey,
fix it.
You fix 100.
Things like that.
Your life will be a lot different.
Now,
I often tell people to fix the things
that you repeat every day because people
tend to think of those as trivial,
right?
You get up,
you brush your teeth,
you have your breakfast.
You know,
you have your routines that you go
through everyday.
Well,
those probably constitute 50 percent of
your life and people think,
well there Monday and I don't need to
pay attention to them.
It's like,
no,
that's exactly wrong.
The things you do every day,
those are the most important things you
do hands down.
All you have to do is do the arithmetic.
You figure it out right away,
so 100 adjustments to your broader
domain of being and there's a lot less
rubbish and there's a lot less rubbish
around at a lot fewer traps for you to
step into and so that's in keeping with
[inaudible] idea about erasing the dis.
Once you've got your mind and your
emotions together and once you're acting
that out,
then you can extend what you're willing
to consider yourself and start fixing up
the things that are a part of your
broader extent.
Now sometimes you don't know how to do
that,
so you might say,
imagine you're walking down bloor street
and there's this guy who's like
alcoholic and schizophrenia and has been
on the streets for 10 years.
He sorta stumbled towards you and you
know,
incoherently mutters something.
That's a problem and it would be good if
you could fix it,
but you haven't a clue about how to fix
that.
You just walk around that and go find
something that you could fix because if
you muck about it that not only is it
unlikely that you'll help that person,
it's very likely that you'll get hurt
yourself.
So you know,
just because while you're experiencing
things announced themselves as in need
of repair,
it doesn't mean that it's.
You write that in there that should
repair them.
You have to have some humility.
You know,
you don't walk up to a helicopter that
isn't working and just start tinkering
away with it.
You have to stay within your domain of
competence.
But most of the time if people look at
their lives,
you know,
it's very interesting thing to do.
I liked the,
I liked the idea of the room because you
can do that at the drop of a hat.
You know,
we go back to where you live and sit
down and think,
okay,
I'm going to make this place better for
half an hour.
What should I do it they have to ask and
things will just pop up like mad and
it's partly because your mind is a very
strange thing.
As soon as you give it a name,
a genuine aim,
it'll reconfigure the world and keeping
with that aim that that's actually how
you see to begin with.
And so if you set it a task,
especially if you have to be genuine
about it,
which is why you have to bring your
thoughts and emotions together and then
you have to get them into your body so
you're acting consistently.
You have to be genuine about the aim,
but once you aim the world will
reconfigure itself around that aim,
which is very strange and,
and it's,
it's,
it's technically true.
You know,
the best example of that,
you have all seen this video where you
watch the basketballs being tossed back
and forth between members of the white
team versus the black team.
And while you're doing that,
a gorilla walks up into the middle of
the video and you don't see it.
It's like you know,
if you thought about that experiment for
about five years,
that would be about the right amount of
time to spend thinking about it because
what it shows you is that you see what
you aim at and that man,
if you can get one thing through your
head and as a consequence of even being
in university,
that would be a good one.
You see what you a map and so because
one
inference you might draw from that is be
careful what you aim at.
Write it.
What you aim at determines the way the
world manifests itself to you,
and so if the world is manifesting
itself in a very negative way,
one thing to ask is,
are you aiming at the right thing?
Now,
you know I'm not trying to reduce
everybody's problems to an improper aim.
People get cut off at the knees for all
sorts of reasons.
You know they get sick,
they have accidents.
There's a random element to being,
that's for sure,
but and so you don't want to take
anything.
Even that particular phrase too far.
You want to bind it with the fact that
random things do happen to people,
but it's still a great thing to ask.
Okay,
so rogers was a phenomenologist and he
was interested in.
He didn't start his philosophy from the
perspective of subject versus object or
from the idea of psyche,
like sort of inside you,
your mind with its layers.
That's not how we looked at it and so
let's go through.
Well,
I'll introduce you to rogers I think,
and then we'll talk about it more next
time.
I'm going to start though with something
that I learned from him that I think it
was of crucial importance and so we'll
set the stage for the further discussion
with this and I'm going to read it to
you.
Assuming a minimal mutual willingness to
be in contact and to receive
communications.
We may say that the greater the
community,
the communicated congruence of
experience,
awareness and behavior on the part of
one individual,
the more the ensuing relationship will
involve a tendency towards reciprocal
communication with the same qualities,
mutually accurate understanding of the
communication's improved,
psychological adjustment and functioning
in both parties and mutual satisfaction.
In the relationship,
it's quite a mouthful.
What does it mean?
Assuming a minimal mutual willingness to
be in contact and to receive
communications.
Okay,
we're having a conversation.
I'm deciding I'm going to listen to you.
Right?
That's different than how people
generally communicate because usually
when they communicate,
they're doing something like,
okay,
we're going to have a conversation and
I'm going to tell you why I'm right and
all win.
If you agree or maybe you're having a
conversation where I don't know what
you're trying to do,
maybe you're trying to impress the
person you're talking to so you're not
listening to them at all.
You're just thinking about what you're
gonna say next.
Okay,
so that's not this.
This is.
You might have something to tell me and
so I'm going to listen on the off chance
that you'll tell me something that would
really be useful for me to know,
and so you could take about it as an as
an extension of the Piagetian.
Piaget talks about the fundamental,
the fundamentally important element of
knowledge being to describe how
knowledge is sought,
the process by which knowledge is
generated.
Well,
if you agree with me and I find that
out,
I know nothing more than I knew before.
I just know what I knew before and maybe
I'm happy about that because it didn't
get challenged,
but I'm no smarter than I was before,
but maybe you're different than me and
so while I'm listening to you,
you'll tell me something I wouldn't.
I don't like.
Maybe it's something I find contemptible
or difficult,
whatever.
Maybe you'll find you'll tell me
something I don't know and then I won't
be quite as stupid and then maybe I
won't run painfully into quite as many
things.
And that's a really useful thing to
know.
Especially if you live with someone and
you're trying to make longterm piece
with them as they are not the same as
you and they're away.
They look at the world and the facts
that they pull out of the world aren't
the same as your facts and even though
you're going to be overwhelmed with the
proclivity to demonstrate that you're
right,
it is the case.
The two brains are better than one,
and so maybe nine of the 10 things they
tell you are dispensable or maybe even
49 out of 50,
but one thing all you need to get out of
the damn conversation is one thing you
don't know.
And one of the things that's very cool
about a good psychotherapeutic session
is that the whole conversation is like
that all you're doing is trying to
express the truth of the situation as
clearly as possible.
That's it.
And so now rogers' proposition,
and I'll tell you why he derived it,
was that if you have a conversation like
that with someone,
it will make both of you better.
It'll make both of you is
psychologically healthier.
So there's an implicit presupposition
that the exchange of truth is curative.
Well,
that's a very cool idea.
I mean,
it's a very deep idea.
Uh,
I think it's the most profound idea.
It's the,
it's the idea upon western civil upon
which Western civilization,
although not only Western civilization,
is actually predicated the idea that
truth produces health.
But for Rogers,
that was the entire purpose of the
psycho therapeutic alliance.
You come to see me because you want to
be better.
You don't even know what that means
necessarily.
Neither do I.
we're going to figure that out together,
but you come and you say,
look,
things are not acceptable to me and
maybe there's something I could do about
that.
So that's the minimal precondition to
engage in therapy.
Something's wrong.
You're willing to talk about it
truthfully and you want it to be better.
Without that,
the therapeutic relationship does not
get off the ground and so then you might
ask,
well,
what relationships are therapeutic and
answered.
That would be if you have a real
relationship,
it's therapeutic.
If it isn't,
what you have is not a relationship.
God only knows what you have.
You're a slave,
they're a tyrant.
You know you're both butting heads with
one another.
It's a primate dominance hierarchy
dispute.
Oh,
I don't know what you're like,
two cats in a barrel or two people with
their hands around each other's throats,
but what you have is not a relationship.